une classe vide avec un avant goût de ce
qui attend ses élèves des adolescents
dans cette école publique leurs pupitres
seront alignés à bonne distance les uns
des autres pour penser en termes
sanitaires la récréation
les activités sportives et parascolaires
et cafétérias pourraient être équipés de
division en plexiglas la rentrée
physique pourrait être graduelle par
groupe d'âge - c'est dans les classes le
ministère a promis de consulter
éducateurs parents et experts sur les
conditions d'un retour en salle de
classe
plusieurs fois reportée même quand la
propagation de lakovic 19 a commencé à
être circonscrite
la situation reste sensible pour les
activités à l'intérieur
comportant des risques de contact
physique nous dit en début avril
l'année scolaire a repris en recourant à
l'une des forces de la corée du sud
la technologie pour donner jusqu'à
nouvel ordre les cours en ligne et pour
trancher un dilemme tout une courbe
d'apprentissage pour bon nombre
d'enseignants du primaire jusqu'aux
études supérieures
ces professeurs en fait l'expérience
dans ce campus qui normalement devrait
bourdonner d'activités en cette période
d'examens
l'important c'est que tous ept accès aux
cours en ligne
[Musique]
pas évident dit-il
pour le gouvernement de fermer aussi
longtemps les salles de classe dans ce
pays où la réussite scolaire fait partie
de la culture bien les établissements
privés dont se spécialiser dans le
tutorat ont toutefois ouvert leurs
portes dans de strictes conditions
sanitaires
ici à libéraux radio canada ces eaux